alright guys bangbang super excited to
have Matt here thank you for doing this
sir thank you for having me on the show
it's great to speak to you absolutely
for those that don't know you let's just
start with with your background where
would you up and kind of what you do
before you started writing books well I
grew up exactly where I'm sitting right
now which is in the northeast of England
and I became very keen naturalist as a
child read biology at university did a
PhD and decided I wanted to become a
journalist moved into writing was a
science editor of The Economist for a
long time and then various other jobs
and then became more and more of a
freelance writer just writing what I
felt like writing books and alongside
that I've done various other things some
successful some less successful in
business and currently about seven years
ago I got myself into the House of Lords
in the UK so I'm a part-time politician
as well as everything else but it is
very much a part-time job it's not a
full-time thing for those that are not
familiar with the House of Lords you
want to explain a little bit about how
it works
yeah well the UK Parliament has two
chambers just like Congress does the
House of Commons and House of Lords the
House of Commons is elected and it has
the vast majority of the power it
decides what legislation goes through
the House of Lords has the power to
delay and revise legislation and it's
mostly appointed but until 1999 it was
mostly hereditary descended from the
original barons who signed the Magna
Carta and all that sort of stuff and in
1999 most of the hereditary --zz were
abolished from the House of Lords but a
small minority remained on the grounds
that you couldn't have a holy appointed
house that would be really undemocratic
so these guys are there to guard the
Constitution and I'm one of those I
inherited a title that gave me the
chance to run for election to a vacant
spot on the House of Lords so I actually
had to win an election
there were 27 candidate
and 48 voters how does that happen well
it's bit like running for dogcatcher in
a small town in rural America I guess
yeah and I guess like what's your take
kind of on democracy today right you
kind of have a unique seat in that
you've written some books that touch on
various subjects may you know both
historical context and modern day but
then you actually get to go practice it
as well and so maybe kind of talk a
little bit about just the change that
you've seen over your lifetime and and
as you sit in that seat today how you
think about it kind of political power
that that certain representatives have
well until ten years ago I was pretty
positive about democracy more and more
countries were becoming democratic the
number of autocracies in the world was
shrinking largely because of the retreat
of communism which had created
autocracies all over the world in Africa
and Latin America and other places and
so more and more people were voting for
their leaders Britain we pretend were a
monarchy with a elected House of look
with an appointed House of Lords but
actually we're a democracy the real
power lies with the elected House and
the Prime Minister and that system
seemed to be working pretty well now in
a lot of countries it still is working
well but you have to admit the last 10
years of not being good for democracy
more and more countries like China and
Russia which seemed to be on a path
towards a more democratic system have
appointed presidents for life and things
like that which is a bad start and even
in democracies which are still
democracies like the United States the
conversation is becoming extremely
polarized extremely angry and an awful
lot of power is accruing to the
officials appointed by Democratic
politicians rather than the Democratic
politicians themselves and I think a lot
of this has to do with the technology of
communication that is
say just as printing kicked off all
sorts of social and political effects
like the Reformation just like radio had
an influence on the rise of the
dictators so I think social media has
polarized society driven us into echo
chambers and filter bubbles and given us
and some pretty severe tensions within
democracies around the world let's hope
we can resolve them yeah it's pretty
crazy how 10 years feels like a long
time when you're living it but in the
grand scheme of human history that's
nothing right and so do you think that
that is actually something that can be
reversed that the last 10 years or do
you feel like once you kind of have that
transition or shift it usually becomes a
slippery slope and it's hard to to get
back on track if you will I think it's
very hard to tell when you're in a
historical period whether it's heading
in one direction or is a temporary blip
that'll be reversed and actually people
are terrible at understanding the future
particularly in complex systems like
democracies but my confidence that we
will get the democratic show back on the
road in most countries is relatively
high communist regimes managed to last
70 years in some places north korea has
lasted about that long as well china
didn't last that long as a communist
regime arguably it became more
democratic but it's still pretended it
was communist now it's going back so in
the grand sweep of history I do not see
the idea of Kings emperors if you like
coming back even if there are
individuals who managed to achieve that
within certain countries like China and
Russia for a short period of time so I'm
hopeful but I'm not as hopeful as I was
a few years ago you're right about that
and when I think back how utopian the
internet felt twenty years ago it is
quite shocking you know I thought once
we were all able to see every bit of
information we would become more rash
and we would see each other's point of
view instead of which there is a
frightening rise in irrationality you
know from the aunt of anti-vaxxer
movement to just people not being
interested in learning the facts about
things and that does concern me yeah and
you wrote the book rational optimist
obviously that has been coming a global
bestseller I've read it and the main
takeaway from it was just hey like you
can actually benefit from being positive
on the future of the world so it's
interesting to hear maybe not pessimism
from you but but a lower degree of
optimism when it comes to some of the
political stuff maybe talk a little bit
about like that framework applied to
today's society you know we live in the
safest most prosperous time in human
history except for if you read headlines
and then if it doesn't may not feel that
way so kind of how do you after writing
the book think about you know current
events today and where the world really
is well setting aside democratic
politics for a minute in every other
respect I think the rational optimist
was bang on and is completely right and
I still adhere to all its its claims
because most of it is about the economic
and medical and other prosperities that
we are experiencing and have been
experiencing and the process of the
processes that have been producing those
improvements in our lifespan health
income our escape from poverty all these
kind of things are continuing there's no
reason to see any diminution in fact it
has been a spectacular decade in that
respect so compared with 10 years ago
the average Ethiopian now owns twice as
much money on average that's pretty
remarkable and that's true throughout a
lot of Africa now when I was publishing
the rational optimist ten years ago
people would quite often say to me yeah
I can see that Asia has made an escape
from poverty but Africa can't possibly
follow can it I mean it's bound to stay
extremely poor forever
and I would say no I don't think so and
I think I'm being proven right on that
sort of kind of thing I wrote the book
during the Great Recession of the
financial crisis of 2008 to ten and that
felt like a possible end of the good
times and the beginning of the bad times
and a lot of people told me it was but I
said no I think we will get the show
back on the road I think we will be able
to improve people's living standards in
the years ahead and then along came the
euro crisis the war in Ukraine the war
in Syria the Ebola epidemic you know the
world everywhere I went in the last
decade there was always a reason for
somebody to say to me you can't still be
a rational optimist given what's
happening X around the world and yet as
I say this has been an extraordinary
decade there's a really beautiful
experiment that Hans Rosling did whose
fellow optimist sadly who died but who
was one of the pioneers of this kind of
thinking swedish health economist and
what he did was he asked a thousand
people in the last 20 years has the
percentage of the world population that
lives in extreme poverty that's a dollar
ninety a day or less doubled half or
stayed the same in those 20 years and in
the u.s. 65 percent of people said it
has doubled five percent said it had
hard the five percent were right the 65
percent were wrong that's pretty
striking
but what Rosling then did was he said if
I had written those three answers on
three bananas and thrown the three
bananas into a cage with a chimpanzee in
it the chimpanzee would have picked up
the right answer 33 percent of the time
not 5 percent of the time it would have
done six times as well as human beings
in answering a question about human
society so what's the problem here the
problem is not that we don't know what's
going on in the world it's that we know
things that are not true we're
absolutely convinced of things that
actually are not true and that seems to
me a growing
that largely because of media coverage
of negative events which is always
happened but is becoming more extreme
all the time that's because of that we
end up with a strong impression that
things are going wrong in the world and
we don't know that they're going right
interestingly when we look at our own
lives we're quite optimistic and why is
that because the media doesn't cover
your own life
and it feels like that media coverage
how much of it is kind of the fake news
disinformation what I'll call kind of
complicit type of coverage versus maybe
they're actually just sharing individual
stories and those individual stories
give the reader listener or watcher that
the feeling that oh this must be
everyone else's story right there's kind
of you know a divergence there in my
opinion of like some of it is very
intentional that leads to what this
thought process your talk about and then
some of it feels like they're just
telling the story of the person that's
in extreme poverty and because that's
the only story they tell and they don't
bounce it with the story of the person
who got out of extreme poverty we then
think oh everyone you know maybe that
way is that makes sense yeah now I think
it's it's it's largely a matter of
omission not commish in other words I
don't think the journalists are going
out there saying I want to tell fibs to
the world about how bad things are what
they are doing is responding to reader
interest in negative stories and you can
do the experiments I mean it's apparent
to be done to say you know choose an
article to read out because this is an
experiment on comprehension and
pronunciation actually it isn't it's a
an experiment to see which articles you
choose people choose the negative
articles so you know I'm afraid bad news
does sell good news is no news if it
bleeds it leads as they say in the
journalism industry so it's it's largely
a matter of the fact that you know just
think about it
you know a war-torn country that is in
the in the in the news for year after
year after year
Angola say or Mozambique in my youth you
know yet another report from this
terrible war where thousands of people
are being maimed by landmines and you
know there's been another attempt at
peace talks which was broken down these
kind of things came out of African
countries all my life sort of thing the
Congo Nigeria
you know countries were in the news
because things were going badly there
and then suddenly you notice one day you
know what Angola is never in the news
these days and when you notice that go
and look up what's happening in Angola
and it's usually because actually the
peace treaty did stick economic growth
is occurring the number of people in
extreme poverty is declining hunger is
on the retreat so it it really is the
fact that the news focus moves away as
soon as things start going right and
that seems a pity every now and then you
get a color peace saying you know
actually life's looking up for the
average Angolan now I'm taking pulling
that one off the shelf I don't know if
there's peace and light in Angola at the
moment but I suspect it's a heck of a
lot better than it was 20 years ago
and you know just the statistics bear
this out by the way Steven Pinker you
know has chronicled the decline of
violence and warfare and he points out
that we've I think we've now got either
10 or 11 Wars going on in the world
right that sounds like a lot it's the
lowest number we've ever had in recorded
history and none of those are happening
in the Western Hemisphere there's not
one going on in Latin America which
there was until a few years ago so
that's never happened before we know how
to hold Hemisphere with no war in it so
let's let's appreciate that things
aren't as bad as we'd like to think for
sure and I think part of being like this
rational optimist is you kind of have to
believe that things will continue to
improve right that the trend is your
friend and it will persist
is there concern that as people are that
rational optimist it then leads them to
not take action right it's kind of like
hey this will continue whether I do
something or not and therefore maybe I
don't need to do anything or actually
does it have the opposite effect which
is the inspiration for people to say I
want to be a part of this and go and act
and and continue to push that forward
well in my new book how innovation works
I tackle this question of where
innovation happens and why it happens in
certain parts of the world and not
others and basically innovation which is
the cause of prosperity only happens
because not not only but mostly happens
where people have already prosperous and
ambitious and rich enough to invest in
new ideas it doesn't happen where people
are desperate where people are
frantically in need of innovation to
save their children's lives or something
like that you know Somalia and Zimbabwe
have not contributed much to new
technologies in the last 20 years so the
idea that necessity is the mother of
invention seems to me simply wrong on
that level and therefore telling people
that the world is is a fantastic place
and you can make it even more fantastic
is I think a better way to inspire them
to be innovators than telling them it's
a desperate place and anything you do is
futile because we're all doomed and I
speak from personal experience here when
I was young the environmental movement
was just getting going a lot of
pessimism was doing the rounds about the
future of the human race there the
population explosion was unstoppable
famine was inevitable lifespan was going
to shorten because of all the pesticides
in the environment the deserts were van
Singh the rainforest was reaching the
Ice Age was coming back the ozone layer
was shrinking on and on and on you know
these gloomy gloomy stories and I
believed them and when I was leaving
school and at university I did not think
the future could be better than the
present and I
thought it would be worse you know I
thought I was heading into a future
where my life was unlikely to be as long
as my parents life where the pollution
would be terrible where things would
just get worse and worse and it was
quite a shock to me and that's probably
why I wrote the book to realize this
wasn't true people were getting richer
and lots of it you know species were
being saved from extinction and air was
getting cleaner and water was getting
cleaner and oil spills were being driven
extinct and famine and virtually
vanished from the face of the earth in
the last decade or two so partly I'm on
an evangelical mission to tell people
young people out there who are hearing
from greater tunberg and everyone else
that the future is bleak and there's no
point in even finishing school because
you it's you're all gonna fry and you
will end up cannibals eating each other
in a year or twos time don't believe
this stuff it isn't necessarily the way
to go and if you think that you're far
more likely to be complacent and
fatalistic than if you think all sorts
of things are possible
yeah what's really interesting we had a
Kathy would come on who's a large asset
manager and one of her thesis is that
during economic crisis innovation
actually gains market share right
there's kind of a deflationary or
compression airy aspect there but can
you help us define the difference
between invention and innovation because
I think that's a key piece of the book
and and also a key aspect that people
need to understand those two things are
not the same yeah well I think Kathy
woods dead right actually that something
happens in bad times to sort of clear
out the undergrowth and leave space for
innovators to come in the 1930s were a
surprisingly inventive decade for
technologies despite being a very bad
decade for people's living standards in
the US particularly but yes you asked
about the difference between invention
and innovation and this is a distinction
I make very clearly in my book because I
think it's very important invention is
coming up with a brand new device or
idea and innovation is turning that new
device or ID
into something that is practical usable
and affordable and available to people
in a large scale now that might seem
like the boring bit innovation coming up
with the the bright new idea is the
exciting bit and that's often the way we
think about it but actually I think
that's wrong I think they're really
interesting and difficult stuff is often
turning a bright idea into something
practical and affordable and useful and
most of the great inventors were
actually innovators who knew how to do
this so someone like Thomas Edison
wasn't particularly the person who came
up with the first lightbulb he was one
of 20 people who produced by an earring
light bulbs but he was the one who made
the light bulb into a practical and
available device that anyone could use
with a lot of work and he talked about
the fact that the invention is 1%
inspiration and 99% perspiration and if
you think about e-commerce and online
commercial activity online retail and
things like that it's not the invention
of the possibility of that but it's the
work of someone like Jeff Bezos making a
huge number of mistakes but in the end
making getting a huge number of things
right as well who is in the end the
great innovator you know the Amazon is
not an invention but it is an
extraordinarily useful innovation that
we all use so my book is very much about
innovation as opposed to invention both
are important but we misunderstand it if
we think that invention is the main
thing you know if you say look it's fine
you've invented the prototype great we
don't need to help you anymore you've
missed out on half the story
yeah and the thing that I think is
interesting in the book is that the
innovation is bottoms up right whereas a
lot of people I think and we talk about
politics earlier where there's kind of
this belief that you can have a top-down
planned society and that will somehow
lead to progress but actually I think
you make the argument of the opposite so
maybe kind of explain that a little bit
as to
how that Bottoms Up approach has led to
innovation over the course of history
yeah I mean I think this is a very
important point ever innovation is an
evolutionary phenomenon it it emerges
from the interactions of ordinary people
and we tell the story about a brilliant
genius sitting down under a tree and an
apple falling on his head or something
like that as if that was the way
innovation happens in occasionally it
can't happen that way but 90% of the
time it is people tinkering with
technologies trying things making
mistakes going down blind alleys and one
company trying one thing and another
company trying another and through this
sifting of these different attempts
there emerges in a sort of bottom-up way
solutions to the problem and it's very
incremental it's very social it's very
evolutionary so I'm trying to get away
from the focus on brilliant individuals
who planned a result even when you can
say this is the person who did it quite
often there's an element of serendipity
that is to say the person set out to do
something and ended up doing something
completely different so the ability to
change your mind is an important part of
innovation the ability to change cause
change direction so in that sense we
really can't and we don't see it coming
that's the other thing we can't see
what's around the corner in technology
nearly as much as we think we can if you
think about the invention of the search
engine I mean I write about steam
engines to search engines as being a
nice sort of bookends of the Industrial
Revolution search engines are probably
one of the most useful inventions of my
lifetime I used them pretty well every
day I've certainly used it today to look
up something and we can't imagine the
internet without them so go back to the
1980s and say look we're about to
develop this thing called the internet
search is going to be the key thing and
that's how people are going to make
money out of it and that's how people
are going to navigate it etcetera
did people say that no they did not
almost nobody forecast the emergence of
search engines let alone the commercial
significance of them and even the people
developing them like Sergey Brin and
Larry Page developing Google they didn't
think they were building a search engine
they thought they were cataloging the
Internet so so in that sense you have to
think of innovation as something that
happens to the world rather than that
clever people impose on the world and
this is part of one of my really big
bugbears which I explored in my book the
evolution of everything which is that
were much too creationist much too
top-down in the way we think about the
world when it you know we think that the
president runs the country we think that
you know God tells you whether to be
moral or not you know we just don't
think of these things as emerging the
famous example which Frederic Bastiat
used to use was how do you feed a city
how do you make sure there's enough food
available in the right place at the
right time so that everybody in London
can have lunch 10 million people eating
lunch every day most of them making up
their minds of what they're going to eat
at the last minute is that something
that is planned and achieved it must be
extraordinary if it is the London lunch
Commissioner must be a very clever
person but of course he doesn't exist
it's a bottom-up phenomenon yeah how do
you kind of put somebody like let's take
Elan musk for example right who's been
involved in various capacities and a
number of innovative things some of
which he was the founder right or kind
of the equivalent of the inventor and
then some of which like a Tesla where
somebody else actually came up with the
idea he stepped in yes he has the title
of founder but really he helped kind of
commercialize and scale the technology
what I'm interested in for somebody like
that is you can do it once and kind of
back into something you know get lucky
to do whatever you want to call it to do
it over and over and over again appears
to be a skill right or some sort of
experience at play there
and circa how does that fit into the
framework where those people are very
rare right so they're definitely
exception in society but how do you kind
of evaluate somebody who can kind of
repetitive
well obviously people who can do that
over and over again extraordinarily
talented and they they they show
inability to to learn from their
experience that is absolutely vital you
know it's I mean someone like Thomas
Edison did this again and again and
again he set up an innovation Factory
the job of which was to produce
innovations and he made lots of people
work for him and work very hard and he
told them to do lots of trial and error
experiments and he got results and that
is certainly a key result but it I don't
think it comes from a particular spark
of genius I think this is where we go
wrong we tend to look at people like
that and think well I could never do
that because I'm not as clever as Elon
Musk or Thomas Edison but actually the
the the secret sauce that these guys
bring is hard work persistence tolerance
of failure ability to learn from their
mistakes Elon Musk has certainly made
mistakes is his solar companies got into
trouble
etc it's not the jury's still out on
Tesla I mean it's hugely dependent on
government grants and things like that
and I say in my book that I think his
ideas of the Hyperloop are probably
extremely impractical so you know it's
not the case that everything they do is
brilliant and I think it's quite
important to get away from that to stop
trying to put these people on a pedestal
and make them into gods and say that
what you know they were partly lucky in
the right place at the right time
partly persistent a huge amount of sort
of pigheaded obstinacy can be helpful
but not so pigheaded Lee obstinate that
you don't change course when the facts
change that's
thing and they were prepared to put in
the hours that's Thomas Edison's remark
about perspiration or inspiration etc so
in a sense I'm trying to demystify these
godlike figures now I'd do it by telling
stories in my book I tell a lot of
stories about how innovations came to be
and I often focus on the key individual
who was involved but I'm not trying to
make them into the author of it I'm
trying to make them into the the subject
of it almost the person to whom this
phenomenon happened and I'm also trying
to put them in the social context of the
other people they relied upon I loved
that and so for those that are listening
who say great I don't have to be some
you know wonder kid genius in order to
to participate in this kind of
innovation arc what can they do to
become more innovative right as you've
kind of studied so many of these stories
are there things that people can
actually do to kind of practice or or
develop that muscle or is this something
that is more just trial and error and go
try to solve problems and it'll come to
you as you kind of put those hours in
well I don't really know the answer to
that question because I'm not I'm not in
the business of training people in
anything and probably would be very bad
out of it if I was and I'm not much of
an innovator myself unless you call a
book an innovation but I think one thing
that it might be worth passing on is the
growth of something called free
innovation so what this refers to and my
friend Andrew Torrence who's a professor
of economics and other things in Kansas
explains has explored this very much
it's it's the user the consumer making
adjustments to technologies to make them
more useful and then sharing them and so
a very nice example of this is the
system called Knight Scout which is used
by parents to monitor the sugar status
of their diabetic
kids in school and essentially it's
about you know the the the the the
real-time data being uploaded to a
network where parents can can keep an
eye on it and this was entirely built by
two or three parents one of whom did one
part of it one of him did another part
of it third added a third layer and so
on and changed the name it what you know
it starts out with it with a gadget from
a pharmaceutical company but the the
whole superstructure of the sort of the
the internet interface with with this
device was built by users and is now
made available through a foundation to
any parent who's in the same situation
the surfboard industry learns a lot from
its users apparently the users make make
adjustments to the shapes and devices on
surfboards and feeds these back to the
manufacturers so I think it's and by the
way there's you know obviously patents
can get in the way of this kind of thing
but shouldn't because actually the law
is if you if you do this and you change
something and it's your own creation
then you can't be stopped from doing it
so it's quite important I think to think
about the fact that you in the way you
adjust and adapt any old device are
yourself being an innovator and all
you've got to do is feed that to other
people in a small way and suddenly
you're a innovative business person yeah
super interesting the title of the book
is how innovation works and and why it
flourishes in freedom and we started
this conversation off talking about
maybe a little less optimism when it
comes to democracies and things on the
political spectrum how do you see
innovation kind of changing if that lack
of optimism ends up being warrant right
so if we head towards a less democratic
world do you think that there is a
negative impact on innovation or are
those two things hopefully insulated
from each other
over the short period of time well
authoritarian regimes generally have a
poor track record in producing
innovations this is true of if you think
about Nazi Germany not not getting
nuclear weapons or all sorts of other
technologies but also it's true of
empires you know the Ottoman Empire the
Ming Empire in China gigantic extremely
wealthy agglomerations of thousands of
people with free trade going on within
them you'd think these would be perfect
places for innovation to happen
but they don't why not because rules are
set from the center by bureaucrats in a
way that doesn't give the innovator the
entrepreneur the freedom to try new
things and so the Ming Emperor's kill
the goose that's being laying golden
eggs for the Chinese economy which
developed in a much more fragmented time
under the song Emperor's by imposing
truly draconian rules on what a merchant
must do and how often he must report
back to the center and whether he's
allowed to leave his home village and
all this kind of thing so trying to tell
people what they can and can't do ain't
good for innovation you have to allow
people freedom freedom to move around
freedom to invest freedom to experiment
freedom to make mistakes freedom to
change your mind all these kind of
freedoms how is it then that China is
currently an innovative country because
it is there's little doubt that some
certainly in the digital area in
artificial intelligence in biotechnology
in other areas China is making strides
into the future not just catching up
with the West in the present and the
answer to that I think is because for
most of the last few decades China has
been a surprisingly free place for
entrepreneurs and innovators so long as
they're not trying to do anything in the
way of democratic innovation like start
a new political party for example so in
other words if long as you don't annoy
the Communist Party you can set up a
business to do something in China much
quickly and with far fewer permissions
than you can in the West and that's been
the secret of their success now whether
that can continue under the regime of
President G who's president for life and
who is increasingly keen on controlling
every aspect of Chinese society I have
my doubts I think he is just like the
Ming Emperor's that preceded him he is
an emperor who is going to kill the
goose that lays the golden eggs and and
I guess part of that is if in China they
have this kind of communist
authoritarian political regime but they
do have let's call it lack of regulation
when it comes to innovation technology
and building companies you could
actually argue in the United States to
some degree we have a free democratic
political regime but actually a pretty
high degree of regulation and so would
you argue then that that high regulatory
bar actually becomes somewhat of a
barrier to innovation or do you feel
like the United States has found maybe
some some equilibrium where there's
enough regulation in general and I'm
over generalization there's enough
regulation to kind of prevent bad things
from happening but still enough room to
allow the innovation to kind of prosper
no I'm very critical of the West Europe
and America in particular to the degree
to which they are stifling innovation
partly with regulation and bureaucracy
as you say partly also with intellectual
property and things like that
and partly with corporate lobbying
against for subsidies and for
regulations against insurgent innovators
this is becoming an increasing problem
it always has been there as a problem
but I think it's getting worse and worse
and in my view the real problem that
regulators bring is delay it's not that
a regulator says no it's that he takes
an age to say yes so in Europe both
shale gas and genetically modified
organisms in agriculture have basically
been
abolished I mean they're not happening
why not these two new technologies that
have brought enormous prosperity in the
United States not because they've ever
been outlawed but because the
permissions you have to get are so
uncertain and takes so long to get I
mean I detail the an extraordinary case
of a blight resistant potato developed
by a German company with genetic
modification who applied for a permit it
got approved by the Scientific Committee
then turned down by the European
Commission etc etc went to the courts at
such a cetera after eight years of this
the company bear Saif said I'm sorry we
can't be bothered with this we're moving
our entire research staff to the United
States to get away from this system this
is not helping so and there is huge
resistance to innovation there is huge
resistance to innovation throughout the
[Music]
Western world and a lot of it does come
from government bureaucracies some of it
also comes from pressure groups from the
likes of friends of the earth and
Greenpeace you know who are well known
to be opposed to many kinds of
innovation so there's an unholy trinity
of big companies not wanting competitors
in their space big government's not
wanting to give permissions for things
and big pressure groups wanting to
exploit people's general fear of the
unknown and the future those three have
indeed given us an innovation famine in
the West
I mean think of medical devices it takes
sometimes up to seven years to get
approval for a new medical device most
entrepreneurs can't afford to wait that
long their money runs out so they're not
going to go into developing new medical
devices they're going to go into
developing a video game or something
like that where you don't need so much
permission
and as a result we get to a pandemic and
we find that we don't have point-of-care
portable instant DNA tests for viruses
something we could have invented ten
years ago frankly and they're not there
because we've over regulated it and
driven them out so in the physical world
that's very hard to kind of get around
because there's actually physical items
in the software or the software world
though much easier to kind of do this
iterative innovation and experimentation
as you mentioned there's still a lot of
regulatory IP issues and things like
that
now part of this is I always go back to
the framework of the laws in the books
are only as good as the enforcement
right and so the US and Europe has done
a very good job of enforcing these laws
right and that's kind of why I think
you're getting that stifling that you're
describing the the difference is now in
today's society there's this idea of
decentralization right so we've seen
that with things like Bitcoin where it's
a decentralized system there's no leader
to call into in front of Congress or
call and arrest or do things like that
and so one of the frameworks I've been
very interested in is Facebook came out
and said hey look we're going to do a
digital currency and immediately
Congress freaked out in the United
States and called in a bunch of
executives and you know pretty much took
them to task and said no you're not
gonna do this and you know why would you
do this and all that I wonder how much
you know going along this line of
thinking of if there is this regulatory
regime that ends up being stifling you
know is decentralization of all sorts of
things not not not just kind of what
people would consider crypto currencies
and things like that but other types of
software does that become a more
important trend because actually what it
does is it very much mitigates the
ability to enforce the rules on the
books again not every industry can do
this wraps of physical items and things
like that are much harder but in
software specifically maybe that is you
know kind of the way that people and
innovators can fight back a little bit
to continue the pace I think that's a
really interesting
and I think it's a very important
concept and I think blockchain generally
enables us to move the next phase of
innovation from California or China or
wherever things are not being looked
after right in terms of regulations into
the cloud into a place which is
stateless and once we do that and they
really can't get at us for to prevent
innovation then surely we can we can do
a lot of good that would be the hope but
of course you can immediately see by me
telling the story in that way
what spooks people and particularly
politicians and journalists about their
story but because I ended that sentence
with the word good you and I could float
off into the ether and do something bad
if that happens and I think the jealousy
of states with respect to currencies is
as nothing to the way the lawyers are
going to react when we say we're going
to have a completely different legal
system that is not tethered to any
territory but is in this in the sky and
it's done through blockchain the the the
you know monopolies don't like you doing
end runs around them and they fight like
tigers to reimpose their monopolies so
the jury's still out on whether
blockchain can achieve that goal of
giving us a sandbox in the sky if I
could call it that where we can do the
experiments that we need to do to
produce new technologies and new ideas
or whether down here on earth
governments will rein in these things I
think you know I often think one of the
most profound things said about
innovation was Amara's law which I
mentioned in the book which is this guy
called Roy Amara who was a computer
scientist futurologist in California in
the 1960s and he said we underestimate
the impact of a new technology in the
long run but we overestimate it in the
short run and this feels to me spot-on
you know when the
Internet is just starting we start to
have wild ideas about e-commerce
replacing retail and replacing
everything else and and we invest like
crazy and comms and then after a few
years everyone says this isn't really
working actually it's not made much
difference the world goes on as before
and everyone gets very disappointed in
you go to combust and then 10 years
later turns out the dream was right so I
think the same will happen with
blockchain I in about ten years time if
we're having this conversation we'll be
saying well didn't really work did it
you know all the blockchain ideas all
the crypto ideas they kind of came to
nothing ten years after that we might be
having a different conversation saying
actually it worked yeah and to me it's
very interesting when you know there's
the decentralization kind of an
ownership model so if you and I want to
build something that maybe regulatorily
is not possible they just don't know who
to call in to get in trouble right or
who to shut down if you will but you
said that can be used for good and bad
but the second piece of what you said
around having this sandbox in the sky is
very interesting right and I think if
you talk to somebody like you know a
Jack Dorsey he's super excited about
things like Bitcoin because he sees it
as like the native currency for the
internet right okay you know definitely
a good chance that could happen but also
you know a high percentage chance that
it doesn't what I'm interested in in
kind of hearing from you is outside of
the currencies when you start to do this
in other areas of innovation in company
building right is there a world that you
see where actually people say look I'm
not going to incorporate in England or
in Delaware I'm going to create this
thing that exists basically in the ether
right it's just a software business and
it operates outside of the existing
legal frameworks you know like you said
that governments are gonna fight that
but but kind of how does that end up if
ultimately people want to do that well I
think this will happen increasingly I
think you
see much more in the way of wholly
decentralized organizations with no
nerve center after all the the internet
is like that already itself if you
wanted to bomb the Internet where would
you start you know if you wanted to shut
down in if you want to switch off the
internet
where would you go which continent would
you start on etc you know it's already
in a sense very much like that and to
some extent this has always been true
the knowledge of how to run the world
has existed in a cloud not not sort of
down here on earth and and I do think
that that we will head more and more in
that direction and I sort of hope we do
because I think I think that there are
really exciting possibilities that are
about getting people in different
nations and why should you be tied to
the rules of one place why should you
not move around after all this echoes
what inventors did in the past so one of
the reasons Europe stole a march on the
rest of the world in the 1500s to 1900s
era was because it was fragmented
politically it was not an empire you
can't unify Europe it's got too many
peninsula sticking out too many mountain
ranges in the wrong place it's you know
Charles v tried it napoleon tried it or
Gustus tried it Hitler tried it and they
never pulled it off for very long and
it's got islands offshore which can act
as aircraft carriers for your enemy
Britain being the first example of that
so it's very hard to unify Europe
it remains fragmented politically
there's another attempt going on at the
moment a unified under one kind of rules
called the European Union that as
results it's in rebellion by the UK
saying no we don't think that's the
right way to operate we'd prefer to have
mutual recognition if your rules are
good and our rules are good that's fine
but we don't have to have the same rule
in Bulgaria as we do in northern
Scotland so and and and what that
resulted in was entrepreneurs
shopping around for a regime they liked
so someone like Gutenberg you know moved
from one area to another in order to
find regime that was congenial for him
to develop printing so that's a sort of
down-to-earth example of the kind of
thing that I think we can create
virtually with the help of technologies
like crypto and so on and as you say to
decentralize these things to move away
from the myth that you know that there's
a headquarters and there's one person in
charge one parallel with this I think is
the idea of a decentralized company
itself the idea that a company doesn't
need a chief executive or a senior
management team is really weird to us
these days but it shouldn't be weird
there's no reason you can't do it there
are some very nice examples actually of
companies that have gone down that route
there's a tomato processing company's
extremely successful in Milton
California that has no chief executive
everybody kind of negotiates their
salary with each other it's a price you
know it's it's basically a collective of
self-employed people as it were it can
be done so I think if I don't sound too
much like a sort of peace and love
hippie and saying so I think there's a
future there yeah and I guess as part of
that when you start to decentralize the
corporation you start sadi Center
decentralized the processes ultimately
what you really are doing is you're
almost taking the governor off of
innovation right because now what you're
actually saying is regardless of if
you're in the authoritarian regimes of
China or you're in the democratic
regimes of the United States in England
you now get into this weird world of it
doesn't actually matter what the laws on
the books are or the the rules that they
have implanted or who is the President
or you know kind of in charge you really
are just opening it up and saying you as
humans what do you want to build right
and to me it sounds like I'm kind of
that's your whole argument here right is
it doesn't
to be just freedom from from a political
sense it's actually the freedom to
experiment the freedom to be innovation
and it's so important I think to always
switch your focus to the consumer not
the producer because that's the person
who's really in charge you know the
decision as to whether or not a
technology is a good technology is taken
by consumers it's not taken by producers
or governments good example of this is
light bulbs actually load bulbs tell
almost every story you want to tell but
you know for hundreds of years for 150
years we had the incandescent light bulb
but it got better and better but it used
quite a lot of electricity and then
Along Came Philips and said we've
invented compact fluorescent light bulbs
they cost a lot more to make so we're
gonna have to sell them for more so
people don't want to buy them and they
don't really warm warm up very quickly
so you have to wait a bit when you go
into a room before it gets light and
that colors not quite right but they use
so much less electricity that we would
like you the government to ban our
competition so that people have to buy
our light bulbs
that's essentially what happened and all
around the world governments did this at
the behest of corporate lobbying and
they basically banned incandescent light
bulbs and forced us all to go out and
buy compact fluorescent bulbs and
consumers didn't like it these things
were difficult to get rid of they were
toxic etc etc they didn't last as long
as they were told within a few years
along came the light emitting diode the
LEDs which naturally displaced both
other technologies very quickly so I'm
sure you have LEDs in your house most
people do nowadays they use far less
electricity than either of the other
technologies they can give you very good
light very instantaneously yes they're
still fairly expensive but they have
saving on electricity is so huge that
they pay for themselves we shouldn't
have gone down the compact fluorescent
route at the behest of governments we
should have let consumers be in charge
of this process and they would probably
have brought the light-emitting diodes
forward we'd probably have had them five
years earlier yeah it's so interesting
how we know this stuff right I mean
literally you wrote a book on it
yet there is the human nature of wanting
to you know have control right when it
comes from the the the leadership side
but before we go to wrap up I'd love to
just kind of hear okay your perspective
you've got this really interesting
understanding of how innovation works
and in kindest rational optimist
viewpoint of the world but then you do
sit in a in a political seat and so kind
of how you when you go to work everyday
like how do you balance those three
things understanding also that like you
can't just wave a magic wand and make
all the decisions right so like kind of
how do you just mentally balance what
many people I think would say are two
very opposing ways yeah no it's a very
good question and compared with the
decisions innovations and entrepreneurs
can take in the real world getting a
decision through a political system is
an absolute nightmare
and it's very rarely do I go smoothly it
very rarely goes quickly it very rarely
gets ended up settled on rationale as
opposed to irrational grounds it's
tremendously frustrating and there are
times when I wonder why why I banged my
head against that brick wall
those who say look all innovation starts
with the government it funds science
it's where it comes from it cetera wrong
for lots of reasons but one of the
reasons they're wrong is then why
doesn't government innovate faster
you know if innovation is coming out of
government you'd think government would
constantly be spinning out these new
technologies look the Department of
Health has invented this thing would the
rest of the world like to take it on
it's called an iPhone you know that
doesn't happen I describe the British
Parliament as a in the book as a
sociological coelacanth you know a
living fossil from the political
Paleozoic you know we we pretend like
we're still in sort of 18th century
England in our procedures
and the very phrases we use now there's
some good things about that it keeps us
polite and we we do respect the
traditions and we make it very hard to
change the constitution of the country
for good reason you know you don't want
to go around suddenly abolishing due
process in the courts or something like
that so but it it it is I am in my day
job
operating in a system that experiences
very little innovation and this has been
brought home in the last few weeks by by
an attempt to turn Parliament into a
virtual thing which has been not
entirely successful shall we say the the
remote work for politicians I have heard
from multiple people now is is an
experiment that probably will not be
continued once we're all allowed out I
think I think that's right I mean in
some ways people were thinking this is
the breakthrough and we'll have remote
voting and things like this but actually
it's it's it's not very satisfactory for
sure I end these conversation with the
same two questions and then you get to
ask me one to finish up the first one is
what's the most important book that
you've ever read other than one of your
own I'll probably say The Selfish Gene
by Richard Dawkins because I read it a
deformative age when I just arrived at
Oxford to read zoology and I discovered
that he was going to be one of my
teachers and he just produced this
extraordinary book which which taught me
that science was about the unknown not
about the mode it was about the mystery
of the world it wasn't about cataloging
facts and that to me was an incredibly
important lesson how important do you
think it was that you read it at that
time where you mentioned that that what
that's like a key piece of that you
think yes I I think the books that
really stick in your mind are the ones
that you read at a turning points in
your life and relatively early in your
life I mean these days I can read a book
love it and two years later not remember
a darn thing about it and have to go
back and reread it
work out what it said so whereas stuff I
read 30 years ago is still there in the
back of my head yeah that's that's
pretty cool and the second question is a
more fun one which is aliens believer or
non-believer oh it's so difficult I've
wrestled with this and I'm fascinated by
it with the Fermi paradox where are they
you know if if there's so many galaxies
out there and so many stars in each
galaxy and so many planets around each
star you know the numbers are ridiculous
then it's simply impossible to believe
were the only ones here and I still
think that yeah I think yes I mean I'm a
believer I know they won't necessarily
be intelligent aliens but there's life
elsewhere in the universe of that I'm
sure as I can be
yeah I tend to follow the exact same
logic the the big question is are they
so far that our technology can't just
can't detect them or find them or the
lately I've heard a number people make
the argument well it could just be
they're on a different time scale right
so they were here it was 500 years ago
right or they're a million years from
now and when you start to get into the
the multi-dimensional analysis of time I
I bow out and say look math says that
there's a high likelihood that's good
enough for me what one question do you
have for me - let's wrap it up what's
the best book you've read last year ooh
last year the best book that's pretty
unfair question because it's hard to
remember these things isn't it that's
literally what I'm going through is
first I have to identify what you know
last year probably was Edward Snowden's
book I would put up oh yes I forget the
name of the book but basically his it's
kind of one of these books where he has
half of the book really dedicated to
kind of his story and kind of you know
the events he went through and then the
other half really was kind of a
statement as to
principles and where he thought the
world was going and his analysis and I
found it I think one fascinating because
it puts some humanity behind a story
that kind of you know really captured
the attention of people around the globe
for you know a number of months but also
to that there's some very kind of
important structural issues that he
looks at everything from surveillance to
cut the data collection and and really
talks about the relationship between
government and its citizens and kind of
you know when those relationships go
well what happens when they go bad so I
just really enjoyed that one
specifically where on where can we send
people to to pick up how innovation
works and then also to learn more about
you or connect with you if they'd like
to okay well my book how innovation
works is available in all good
bookstores including online ones such as
Amazon and it's been available for a
couple of weeks now in the US and it's
available in the UK from the week after
next so should be available worldwide at
some point awesome and then if you want
to get in contact with you if they want
to get in contact with me my website the
rational optimist comm is the best way
to find me awesome Matt listen I
appreciate you taking the time to do
this you've you've written a number of
awesome books and I tend to think that
the work you're doing is very important
for people to go consume so hopefully
we'll get some people over there and
watch this again in the future
Thank You Anthony I really enjoyed it